Ronald is brought up no less than three
times in King's novel most notably by
Don Hagerty who after witnessing
Pennywise kill his boyfriend claimed
that the clown looked like a cross
between Ronald McDonald and Boza
Ronald's plan seemed to be working
because after these initial commercials
which aired around Washington DC he
became a local celebrity and gained a
lot of influence over children near the
nation's capital this led to him being
introduced nationally in 1966 before
appearing on the national stage Ronald
got his first of many makeovers dropping
the drink cup nose and Trey hat and
adopting a more traditional clown
costume is it Co incidence that this
look would seemingly go on to inspire
serial killer John Wayne gasy or was
that simply the standard clown look at
the time I'll let you decide in what
some sources have documented as the
First National Commercial Ronald helps
paint a McDonald sign sticks around for
lunch then takes off in his flying
hamburger mobile obviously another
demonstration of his occult power